I'll breathe it's time to turn your test
now
hey Carly what's going on over here
couldn't even answer one question listen
I have a colleague
Tamara Thompson she is an excellent
tutor mrs. Dobson is you're starting
your math lessons Cameron please mrs.
Thompson is a little formal for tutoring
shop that's the same car what's going on
where are you going we're done
hey you what are you doing out here you
having a rough night
no not really I'm fine you need a ride
tomorrow
I am completely free and I'm gonna go to
Santa Monica Pier would you want to join
me that sounds like a lot of fun and how
did your parents meet I don't know if
you know this but that is actually my
stepmom do you mind if I ask about your
real mother I don't know much about my
real mom
Tamara's driving her to school they seem
to really get along I don't think that's
healthy
I hope you know how much this time is
meant to me I feel the same yeah her
name is not Tamra Thompson her real name
is Christina Miller about 13 years ago
her daughter was abducted and they never
found her your father's firing me what
she is not who she says she is she's my
friend he's a disgusting human being I
can't even believe that he's my father
everything's gonna be all right you need
to get out of here can you pick me up
please just take me away from here I'll
take care of you you're safe this is a
picture of me when I was 15 you look
like me
Babri you were my daughter like where's
my daughter she's not here
Debra what did you tell her I told her
the truth you abducted me
you